[Music]
let's go to moorfield west virginia alex
is there alex how can we help
hi thank you for taking my call
so i'm 19 years old and i have more debt
than i would really like to have and
i honestly it kind of feels like a
pretty heavy weight and i just want to
know what my steps should be as far as i
some of the things are valuable and i
feel like i can
i can get my way out of this and never
get back into this and so i just
uh i just i just wanted to talk to the
people who know best so alex riddle me
this how much debt would you like to
have
none
perfect answer okay i just need to know
the level before we continue that helps
me
okay so 50 how much debt do you have
total
58 000. wow what kind of debt
okay so i have 22
dollars debt in a new truck
i have twenty four thousand eight
hundred dollars debt and a john deere
tractor
and then i have seven thousand six
hundred dollars debt and some
landscaping equipment that i do uh for a
side hustle with my neighbor we have
some equipment together and then i have
a personal loan for two thousand seven
hundred dollars that is just leftover
negative equity from where i've already
sold out of a lot of debt
are you in like uh are you in business
with this john deere tractor or is this
just a big toy
okay well essentially it's become a big
toy because i've been fortunate enough
to get a really good job i work from
home in the retirement industry and i
love it and i'm kind of getting out of
out of these these smaller things
because it wasn't really panning out it
wasn't it wasn't bringing in what i was
sending out for it is the tractor are
you upside down in the tractor or is it
still worth more than what you owe on it
or worth the same
it is worth about the same with plus or
minus fifteen hundred dollars so
manageable sweet so how much do you make
um so with my new job i make about forty
eight thousand uh
as i say i have some other income coming
in from the side hustle that my neighbor
and i do landscaping stuff with
essentially lawn mowers not related to
the tractor okay what's the truck worth
the truck is worth a little better than
60 000. what the truck is worth 60k and
you owe 22.
yes sir i it's a case i'm very
passionate about vehicles it's a truck
that i've saved a lot through my
childhood and a lot through
my first working years and i put a ton
of money i knew better than to go into
debt i did it anyways i've put a ton of
money down and i've put everything i've
made this year from both jobs on it
trying to knock it out because it's like
5.4 percent interest i'm watching that a
cure every day is killing me hey alex
alex if we want to talk about interest
you're on the wrong show man i'm trying
to help you become debt free that's what
i'm passionate about sell it
so here's the deal the truck is gone
today the tractor is gone today you're
debt-free today
and some some money left over and some
money left over which is going to become
your emergency fund because i assume you
don't have a lot in savings
i do how much do you have
about 13 000
okay
well you won't have to touch that 13
that will become your emergency fund if
you do all these things now the question
is are you willing to sell the truck in
the tractor today
to be debt-free
yes are you willing to pay the price
that certainly sounds like what i need
to do are there other trucks out there
are there other pieces of metal on
wheels that you could love one day
certainly are that's what i figured and
can we do it all with cash going forward
and any side hustles we do we do with
cash going forward
yes
how about the landscaping equipment can
you sell that
i can do you need it because it sounds
like the side hustle is not panning out
versus the 8 000 debt you have on the
equipment uh
yeah i can sell it and i think that
would be my best bet it's a good move
because if you want to keep messing
around on the side hustle with the
landscaping job that's fine but you can
rent the equipment you build that into
your job
you know renting that equipment is very
affordable if that's something you want
to continue to do i would sell all of
those things man now you're debt free
you've got a nice emergency fund you can
still buy a decent truck
so what would you suggest them as far as
a vehicle
a decent truck with what we can afford
you make 48k
and our rule of thumb is everything with
a motor in it doesn't add up to more
than half of your annual income which
means everything with a motor in it that
you own shouldn't add up to more than 24
000.
so if i'm you i'm if whatever cash you
have left over that's not your emergency
fund leave that at three to six months
of expenses outside of that get a
reasonable truck for 15 20 grand that's
what i'm doing if i'm in your shoes
i understand
now the question is are you going to go
back into debt for some other you know
harebrained idea down the road
no no that won't happen i'm already
working on how i wanted to go about
getting out of this debt and saving up
to purchase some property up front with
cash
i like that's a different mindset you're
very ambitious and i like this and keep
in mind you can always buy a used
tractor if you're just putting around on
the tractor with a car i don't even
i don't even think i need it i think
looking at it now it was just a mistake
yes of course well it's all right you
paid a stupid tax but the truth is you
can reverse all of this very easily
right now because of the market
and uh because of them being vehicles
and tractors oh so i'm undoing this
thing asap man and once you you're out
of debt with a pile of cash never look
back never touch dead again at 19 you're
gonna be unbelievably wealthy if you do
that thank you for the call alex